yesterday we had some pretty brief and
limited information about Donald Trump's
tax plan proposal when we taped the show
I Mac I'm three hours earlier here in
Las Vegas so it was actually pretty
early morning when we taped the show and
later in the day more information was
released about Donald Trump's tax plan
we now have more to comb through and
think about we still don't have that
much because the way in which a lot of
the sort of mechanics of it are going to
work have been missing from the plan
including from what we've heard from the
White House including from what we've
heard from Steven minuchin but at least
from what we have we now can make a
little bit more detailed of an analysis
and try to get a better understanding of
what the impact would be of what Donald
Trump is proposing to do with taxes
including the economic repercussions of
what he's trying to do so there's six
primary actions that we understand and
have deduced our part of Donald Trump's
tax proposal and we'll go through them
one through six number one there's going
to be a proposed reduction of individual
tax brackets now these are federal tax
brackets so whatever state tax you have
or none at all depending on what state
you live in on income that's separate
from this the proposal would reduce the
number of individual tax brackets to
only three a ten percent bracket a
twenty five percent bracket and a thirty
five percent bracket this will lower
taxes for a majority of individuals but
what's really important here is how
these reductions are going to be
distributed and we'll get to that a
little bit later okay number two from
Donald Trump's tax plan it would double
the standard deduction to twenty four
thousand dollars for a couple filing
jointly okay so a standard deduction is
when you do your taxes let's say you
make $40,000 and you had ten thousand
dollars in what would be called
qualifying deductions you would lift
those on your tax return and the $10,000
in deductions would make your adjusted
income only
thirty thousand dollars and you would be
taxed only on thirty thousand dollars
even though you made forty thousand
dollars only thirty thousand dollars are
taxable based on your deductions however
for most people their individual
deductions are as they're called
itemized deductions are not that high so
the IRS provides what's called a
standard deduction which everybody can
take regardless of what their actual
deductible expenses are the joint the
married filing jointly tax deduction
this year is twelve thousand seven
hundred dollars Donald Trump would
nearly double that to twenty four
thousand dollars for a single person in
2017 it's nine thousand three hundred
and fifty dollars and my guess is that
that would also go up to a little more
than half I would assume of that twenty
four thousand dollars so if you have
more than the standard deduction in
deductions you can deduct more but
everybody can take the standard
deduction and couples filing jointly
will be able to take a twenty four
thousand dollar tax deduction now that
will decrease the taxes you pay but it
relates to item number three on Donald
Trump's tax plan which is that there
will be an elimination of most itemized
tax deductions there's two major tax
deductions that are very popular and
that apparently would stay in Trump's
plan those are the mortgage interest
deduction meaning if you have a mortgage
each monthly payment you make you're
paying some principal and some interest
the interest that you pay over the
course of the year on your mortgage is
deductible it lowers your adjusted
income and charitable contributions the
tax deduction for charitable
contributions would stay so the standard
deduction would go up the ability to
take as many itemized deductions would
go down number four and this is where we
really start to get into the huge
windfall for the rich for Donald Trump
for his friends there would be a total
repeal of the estate tax as well as the
alternative minimum tax
now why is this so relevant to Donald
Trump two reasons number one Donald
Trump has a very very large estate he
has a lot of money what exact amount of
money you think he has doesn't really
matter it's a lot of money and uh by
eliminating the estate tax Donald Trump
will personally benefit in terms of the
amount of money that he will be able to
pass on to his children grandchildren
etc so Donald Trump and in fact many of
trumps cabinet members the number of
billionaires on Trump's cabinet will
benefit significantly from this and
number two you might remember that what
I consider totally overblown Rachel
Maddow segment where she had one or two
pages of Trump's 2005 taxes which told
us almost nothing but one of the things
that we did learn from those taxes is
that most of the taxes that Donald Trump
did pay in 2005 were paid because of
this thing called the alternative
minimum tax and by eliminating the
alternative minimum tax again it would
be a huge major windfall for Donald
Trump's family for many of his friends
for many of his political appointees
cabinet members etc number five Trump's
tax proposal would end the 3.8%
obamacare investment income tax so this
is a tax that was put in place by
Obamacare to fund some of the expenses
associated with Obamacare the
elimination of that investment income
tax used to fund Obamacare would
disproportionately help those who pay
taxes on investment income and who are
they well they're much more likely to be
the upper middle class the rich the
super-rich the mega rich the ultra super
mega rich the people really at the very
very top so another big big boon for
Trump and his buddies and number six
Donald Trump would reduce the business
tax rate to 15 percent I don't want to
dig that much into that piece right now
but obviously the bigger your business
the better this is for you the current
rate on paper is 35
but something that's really important to
keep in mind is that we often hear the
right point to the just incredibly high
business tax rate in the United States
it's not true that thirty five percent
is the highest business tax rate in the
world but very few businesses are
actually paying thirty five percent
because a lot a number of different
accounting mechanisms many of which
we've talked about on the program over
the last several years allow businesses
to significantly reduce their effective
tax paid so it's again trying to solve a
problem that's not a problem
the 35% tax rate in the US on businesses
is not paid by huge huge businesses many
of them actually pay zero effective tax
rate so what will this do to the
national debt because Republicans claim
to care about the national debt
particularly under President Obama they
really cared about it the national debt
would increase drastically as a result
of a major increase to the deficit of
course the debt is the accumulated debt
the deficit is the year-to-year surplus
or shortfall in terms of government
inflows and outflows of money Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin was asked
well what's going to happen how are you
going to pay for all this and he said
simply that this will pay for itself and
that the quote closing of loopholes
would pay for the tax cuts which would
drastically increase the deficit that's
just not true we've seen no evidence to
suggest that later in the show I'm going
to talk to you about how historically
cutting taxes in this way has never been
a good thing for the economy and as
usual Republicans cared about the debt
and the deficit when President Obama was
president even though President Obama
cut the deficit the debt still went up
because we still had a deficit but the
deficit was reduced under Trump vague
claims that the tax cuts will pay for
themselves are somehow acceptable tax
cuts for the rich have never helped the
economy and here's the goldmine Donald
Trump argued during the campaign for a
very long time that it doesn't matter
whether he
policies would increase the deficit on
paper because they would so
significantly improve the economy that
they would pay for themselves by growing
the economy so I hope you're sitting
down for this
Steven minuchin said that the tax
changes
Donald Trump has proposed would spur the
economy to grow by 3 percent 3 percent
Donald Trump slammed Obama just last
year for having only 2.6 percent growth
this entire plan this huge overhaul
which is a massive gift to corporations
and to rich people is going to get us
from 2.6 percent growth under Obama
which according to Trump was not
acceptable to 3 percent growth after all
of this deficit exploding overhaul and
series of changes absolutely and utterly
stunning